foreign
goes viral for the many many faces he
made at the coronation the main thing
that I look for is I think on a micro
expressions and with Harry we see
sadness frustration anxiety I think he
felt very uncomfortable the Duke of
Sussex had no formal role in the
ceremony and he didn't make contact with
his dad King Charles nor his brother
Prince William during the big day I
fully expect Prince Harry to be very
much on the sidelines during this
Ceremony this ceremony is all about King
Charles III and the queen consort but
naturally all eyes were on the embattled
Royal as he attended the festivities
there's going to be thousands of people
around so hopefully for Harry that's
going to take the emphasis off him Harry
was spotted entering Westminster Abbey
on Saturday morning with his cousins
Princess Beatrice princess Eugenie and
Zara Tyndall and seemed to be in good
spirits everyone wanted to see that
moment when Harry arrived but I think we
saw him quickly put at ease was he was
alongside princess Eugenie Princess
Beatrice and their husbands and over the
course of the ceremony Royal followers
took note of his many expressions like
this out of context Grimace at a passing
Royal a big smile for his aunt Anne we
saw him sharing jokes with Princess Anne
a laugh with Princess eugenie's Husband
Jack Brooksbank a more serious moment
during the ceremony a cheeky moment with
religious leaders and some possible side
eye at his brother although William knew
that Harry was attending the coronation
ceremony there was certainly no effort
to reach out to his brother before this
trip to have any kind of dialogue before
that moment in Westminster Abbey where
they may or may not have locked eyes and
I think that just shows how broken the
relationship is my personal favorite
this straight to camera shot that is
giving major gym from the office vibes
that is his choice and lastly a big grin
as he got into a black BMW after the
ceremony to head home to Los Angeles for
his son Archie's fourth birthday when
Harry left it was clear that he had made
his own arrangements to get back to
California and so his plans including
the flight that he was on were kept top
secret into who was actually back on the
plane back home prior to the event E.T
learned Harry would attend the
coronation alone while his wife Megan
Markle and their two kids Archie and
one-year-old lillibet would stay home in
California the fact that he's going solo
seems surprising Until you realize that
it's actually Archie's birthday the very
same day which is perhaps quite
convenient given the tensions between
the two families right now now a source
tells ET that King Charles wished Prince
Archie a happy birthday during a private
family gathering on Saturday after his
coronation the well wishes came during a
toast to those who were not in
attendance according to our source Harry
was invited to the lunch but left as
soon as the service was over he was
welcome to join any of the festivities
that he wanted to of course it was
Archie's birthday back in California she
also wanted to be his support his dad so
he chose to split the day into two
although Harry wasn't part of that lunch
that took place at Buckingham Palace
King Charles actually made a toast to
Prince Archie so I think for Charles
Harry certainly was friend of mine
[Music]
thank you